si observamos la estructura de una
acetona sabemos que encontraremos una
señal en el espectro
r correspondiente al carbón y lo de la
acetona porque el oxígeno es
parcialmente negativo y este carbono es
parcialmente positivo así que una
separación relativamente grande de las
cargas significa que hay un cambio en el
momento dipolar del carbón y por lo
tanto obtendremos una señal muy fuerte
que aparece en aproximadamente 1700
15.720 pero es un poco diferente para un
acetona conjugar la conjugación hace que
la señal aparezca en un número de onda
menor veamos la resonancia que tiene
esta molécula si movemos estos
electrones hacia acá estos electrones se
mueven hacia el oxígeno y nos queda un
doble enlace
y después tenemos un enlace simple entre
el carbono y el oxígeno que ahora tiene
tres pares de electrones libres así que
tenemos una carga formal negativa en el
oxígeno y una carga formal positiva en
este carbono entonces estos electrones
en rosa se movieron hacia acá y estos
electrones en azul se quedaron en el
oxígeno recuerden que en realidad la
estructura de la molécula es un híbrido
de las estructuras de resonancia
observen que la estructura de resonancia
de la izquierda tiene un doble enlace
carbono oxígeno pero en la estructura de
la derecha tenemos un enlace simple
entonces dibujaré un carbono unido al
oxígeno pero aquí tenemos un enlace
parcial eso significa que tenemos un
enlace más fuerte que un enlace simple
pero no tan fuerte como
un doble enlace porque la resonancia
debilita al doble enlace en el carbón
hilo y si debilitamos los enlaces
recuerden que el valor de la constante
de fuerza k disminuye en vídeos
anteriores
dijimos que al disminuir k disminuye la
frecuencia o número de onda así que la
señal para este carbón y lo aparece en
aproximadamente 1600 80 y eso se debe a
que la resonancia debilita la fuerza del
doble enlace ahora qué pasa cuando
tenemos un átomo electro negativo aquí
tenemos un derivado general del ácido
carboxílicos donde ya representa algún
átomo electro negativo como por ejemplo
oxígeno en este caso también podemos
tener resonancia si movemos un par de
electrones libres hacia acá empujamos a
estos electrones hacia el oxígeno y nos
queda
el oxígeno de arriba con una carga
formal negativa y la y con una carga
formal positiva entonces el par de
electrones libres formó el doble enlace
y estos electrones py en el carbón y los
se quedaron en el oxígeno ahora si
pensamos en nuestro híbrido de
resonancia observen que la fuerza del
doble enlace se debilita y como ya vimos
al disminuir k disminuye el número de
onda en el que encontraremos la señal
disminuye la frecuencia de vibración del
doble enlace esto es lo que sucede
cuando hay resonancia ahora al hablar de
un ácido carboxílicos también tenemos
que tomar en cuenta el efecto inductivo
hay una competencia entre la resonancia
y la inducción si tenemos un grupo r el
carbono oxígeno y un átomo electro
negativo que pensemos en que el doble
enlace
esté habilitado por la resonancia pero
qué es la inducción bueno la inducción
se refiere a la electro negatividad de
ese átomo si tenemos un átomo muy
electro negativo este retira densidad de
electrónica en esta dirección
supongamos que un par de electrones
libres en el oxígeno se mueven hacia acá
para fortalecer al carbón y lo y si
retiramos densidad electrónica un poco
de la densidad electrónica del oxígeno
se mueve para incrementar la fuerza del
carbón y lo esto provoca que tengamos el
doble enlace de nuevo entonces esta es
la inducción
inducción al retirar densidad
electrónica aumentamos la fuerza del
carbón hilo y por lo tanto aumentamos la
constante de fuerza k y la frecuencia de
vibración del enlace así que esperamos
encontrar la señal en un número de onda
alto entonces estos son los efectos que
compiten y hay que tomarlos en cuenta
cuando hablemos de los derivados del
ácido carboxílicos la resonancia
debilita la señal y la inducción la
fortalece ahora veamos algunos
compuestos que tienen un grupo carbón
hilo y analicemos las diferentes señales
en el espectro y r
aquí tenemos algunos compuestos que
contienen un carbón y lo esperamos
encontrar la señal del carbón y lo en un
rango de número de onda de
aproximadamente mil 850 a 1650 en algún
punto de este rango esperamos encontrar
la señal si bajamos a 1740 podemos
pensar en que aquí se encuentra la señal
promedio por lo tanto también tenemos un
valor promedio de la constante de fuerza
que ahora para un esther el efecto
inductivo es un poco más fuerte que la
resonancia y ya vimos que ayuda a
fortalecer el carbón y lo así que
aumenta un poco el valor de acá y si
aumentamos el valor de acá aumenta el
número de onda en el que encontraremos
la señal porque si aumentamos acá
aumenta la frecuencia de vibración y por
lo tanto aumenta el número de onda
así que el número de onda aumenta de
1740 a aproximadamente 1745 aquí es
aproximadamente donde encontraremos la
señal para el carbón y lo de un tester
ahora vamos con el anhídrido de ácido
aquí el efecto inductivo es más
importante porque podemos pensar en que
este oxígeno es muy electro negativo y
eso significa que tendremos un valor más
alto de acá así que tenemos un carbón y
lo más fuerte si tenemos un valor alto
de acá también aumenta la frecuencia de
vibración y esperamos encontrar esta
señal en un rango de número de onda de
aproximadamente mil 760 a 1.790 esta es
la primera señal para un anhídrido de
ácido así que corresponde a un
estiramiento simétrico
observen que tenemos dos grupos carbón
hilo y al estirarse en fase esa es la
señal que esperamos encontrar pero
también tendremos un estiramiento
asimétrico así que tendremos otra señal
como la que vimos en el vídeo anterior y
vimos que se necesita más energía para
un estiramiento asimétrico así que esta
señal se encontrará en un número de onda
de aproximadamente 1810 entonces tenemos
dos señales en nuestro anhídrido de
ácido ahora para el cloruro de asilo o
cloruro de ácido el efecto inductivo
domina completamente al efecto de
resonancia entonces el cloro retira un
poco de densidad electrónica y el carbón
y lo se fortalece aún más la constante
de fuerza aumenta más y por lo tanto
tenemos un valor más alto de la
frecuencia de vibración por lo
la señal para este carbón y lo aparece
en un número de onda de aproximadamente
1800 o 1815 aproximadamente en este
rango encontraremos la señal para el
carbón y lo en el cloruro de asilo muy
bien ahora vamos en la otra dirección si
ésta es nuestra constante de fuerza
promedio muy cercano a la señal del
número de onda promedio tenemos un
aldehído observen que aquí tenemos un
hidrógeno así que en este caso no
tenemos un átomo electro negativo en los
ejemplos anteriores tenemos oxígeno y
cloro pero aquí tenemos hidrógeno así
que no tenemos que preocuparnos por el
efecto inductivo ahora aquí tenemos un
grupo alquilo donador de electrones este
grupo alquilo dona un poco de densidad
electrónica por lo que perdemos un poco
de densidad electrónica
en el carbón y lo cargas iguales se
repelen así que disminuye la fuerza del
carbón y lo disminuye la constante de
fuerza acá y si disminuye acá entonces
en este caso esperamos que la señal
aparezca en un número de onda de
aproximadamente mil 725 todos estos
valores son aproximados no estoy
diciendo que sean exactamente estos
valores pero son muy cercanos
aquí es donde esperamos encontrar la
señal para el carbón y lo de un aldehído
ahora comparemos el aldehído con un ace
tone observen que un acetona tiene dos
grupos al kilo y como tenemos más grupos
donadores de electrones el carbón hilo
se debilita más y al debilitar el carbón
y lo que disminuye más que antes
entonces esperaríamos encontrar la señal
para el carbón y lo de la acetona en un
número de onda más bajo
aproximadamente en 1700 15.720 aquí es
aproximadamente en donde encontraremos
la señal para el carbón y lo de la
acetona muy bien ahora vamos con el
ácido carboxílicos si tenemos un ácido
carboxílicos voy a dibujar otro por acá
si tenemos un ácido carboxílicos en la
forma de américa se pueden formar
enlaces con otros hidrógenos y eso
provoca que el carbón hilo se debilite
aquí podemos pensar en que un poco de
densidad electrónica se mueve hacia acá
y por lo tanto eso disminuye mucho más
el valor de la constante de fuerza en
comparación con el valor promedio así
que para el ácido carboxílicos esperamos
ver la señal en aproximadamente 1700 10
aunque puede variar porque todo depende
de algunas cosas como la forma en este
caso tenemos la forma de américa
finalmente vamos con la amiga que
también es un derivado del ácido
carboxílicos si pensamos en la
resonancia compitiendo con la inducción
en este ejemplo la resonancia dominga si
movemos estos electrones hacia acá
empujando a estos electrones
hacia acá la fuerza del carbón y lo se
debilita y como la resonancia es
dominante el valor de k disminuye
muchísimo en comparación con el valor
promedio y por lo tanto disminuye el
número de onda en este caso la señal
aparecerá en un rango de aproximadamente
mil 650 a 1.690 recuerde estos valores
son aproximados y al pensar en la
resonancia la inducción la electro
negatividad y los grupos alquiló
donadores de electrones así como en los
enlaces con otros hidrógenos nos permite
saber aproximadamente en donde
encontraremos la señal y así podemos
conocer la fuerza del carbón y lo